grade 3 teacher Christy chippenack has
been living with terrible tastes and
smells for nearly a year there are very
few Foods she can tolerate lettuce and
tomatoes are still my Staples mostly
other things either taste like dirt or
just tastes like they've already gone
bad to Christy most meat tastes rotten
coffee smells like gas her disorder is
called parasmia it showed up shortly
after she had covid-19 when Christy
shared her story with global news last
may she hoped relief would come soon it
didn't instead she's learning to cope
and making videos about it I don't add
banana anymore because they taste like
chemicals unfortunately Quebec
researcher Johannes fresnelli says smell
and taste issues still affect many
infected with covid we know now it
depends a little bit about on on the
variants that we're looking at but
approximately 60 percent of of infected
people lose their sense of smell in the
acute phase in his study of health care
workers how who lost their smell said it
was not back to normal a year later the
others that they smell they don't smell
as they are supposed to smell so instead
of vanilla they would smell let's say
burnt rubber or something like that
Edmonton's long covid Clinic continues
to see patients with parasmia and
anosmia or no smell the most common
treatment is olfactory training several
times a day they just open up the vial
and they practice smelling kind of like
resetting the sensors and the uh and the
part of the brain that um that uh
perceives smell Christie says the only
thing that's helped her so far is
connecting with others with porosmia
they tell me like oh my gosh I thought I
was the only one and it does feel like
that and it can be very isolating online
support groups share tips and recipes
Bland Cuisine Christy hopes she won't
have to eat for much longer I cannot
wait I have a whole list of things I'll
be having that day let me tell you sue
lingo Global News